general framework and how we can operate
in a more privacy-preserving way in this
framework and the general framework is
one of privacy in cloud storage where we
some user Alice will call Alice wants to
outsource her data to a cloud and access
this in a very primitive way of just
reading and writing cells indexed to you
know key words or addresses in this
storage device the idea is that the
storage is probably too large or she
doesn't have a persistent way to
maintain it and she wants then this
server Bob to take care of this data for
her the challenge though is that she
does trust Bob to keep her data safe and
sound and and available but she does not
trust Bob to try to keep it confidential
and so it's her responsibility to
achieve some degree of privacy for her
data that's her goal so the first thing
she's definitely gonna do is to encrypt
her data and so that every time that she
you know write to sell to you know
writes data to some cells she'll encrypt
it when she reads it she you will always
be reading an encrypted value so the
only thing that Bob can ever see are
encrypted values and moreover she's
going to use some degree of
randomization in this encryption so even
if she was reading and writing the same
value multiple times each time she would
read and write it it would come back and
be stored with a different random number
indexed into that so the Bob could even
not even correlate the fact that she was
reading and writing the same value over
again but the bad news for Alice is that
even just encrypting the values still is
not enough to achieve
IVA see because she still is is telling
Bob the indices she's using to access
those cells and so if there's hotspots
in her data in terms of the access
sequences then Bob is learning her
access sequences so it was an example of
this if you were to if you were at the
talk on Monday by Joseph Gonzalez he
showed this video of this learning
algorithm for a digital image where if
you were just looking at the access
sequences you could actually see the
image sort of appear in front of you had
this video if you remember of doing that
and so the idea is that in that sort of
a framework where you are you know doing
an algorithm that could be revealing
information about your data just from
the access sequence you want to hide it
somehow not only the values but also the
access sequence and so that's what this
framework is all about how can you
simultaneously be hiding the data values
and the patterns that you use to access
those data values and so for this
framework we call it the oblivious data
storage so you have alice has this some
private memory that she has you know
much smaller of some size K that then
she wants to use as allocate Scratch
storage space so that she can access her
data that is outsourced to Bob and she
wants to do this with low overhead and
she wants to then hide her access
patterns so you don't see any V hotspots
and one way that we can achieve that is
to use something that we call it the
date of Bolivia's framework of course
she's going to be encrypting her data
but she's also then going to be using
what we call a data oblivious
computation and a date oblivious
computation is a computation where the
sequence of accesses that you do to the
data does not depend on the input values
it's it's either always the same no
matter what the input values are or
you're using some sort of random
processes but the random bits you use
and the the how they influence the
accesses again doesn't depend
on the input values it's just random
permutations based on the Brindavan bits
not on the values of what you're
actually processing you're nevertheless
also allowed to use some sort of black
box computations internally so she can
you know read one two three if you know
some small number of values from the
storage do some local computations
herself and the adversary this Bob
server does not see what her local
computations are so we you know think of
those as sort of black box computations
therefore then the control flow of her
algorithm only depends on the input size
how big is her data and possibly the
value of these random variables she
would use in this process and then
having said that there's sort of two
broad-brush approaches you can take to
this approach and we've worked on sort
of different aspects of both of these so
the first is that you want to have some
general method that can you know do this
sort of as a compiler almost that would
take some algorithm that does have data
dependencies that does you know it's not
in itself data oblivious and it converts
it into an algorithm that would be
oblivious actually when you do this
conversion there's going to be some
overheads you're going to be introducing
some redundancies and therefore there's
some expense to that generality and so
you have what we call some of this
overhead of each access that the
original algorithm would make now it's
going to translate into multiple maybe
order log n log squared n or even log
cubed n accesses in this you know
obfuscated version of that same
algorithm or alternatively if you have
some specific computation that you want
to perform and you don't mind leaking
the fact that you're doing this
algorithm but at the same time you're
not going to reveal the value so you
okay we're gonna do a learning algorithm
or we're going to do this image
processing algorithm and we're revealing
the fact that we're doing this specific
algorithm but not revealing the values
then you can design you know your
algorithm to be itself a date oblivious
algorithm
from the beginning so for example a lot
of dynamic programming algorithms are
just standard loops that you just go
through and you fill in a table and
access sequences you do in that
algorithm are themselves data oblivious
so you could just use that algorithm say
okay i'm revealing i'm doing a dynamic
programming algorithm but that's really
all you're revealing is that one fact so
let's start first with the general
simulation results that we have done so
for example we were able to achieve if
you have for Alice if she just has a
constant number of registers then she's
able to achieve an order log squared n
overhead for this conversion if she just
has a little bit of memory n to the
epsilon amount of memory but not
constant then we can get the overhead to
be order log n and if she has
simultaneously that n to the epsilon
memory and the messages that she uses to
communicate with Bob are themselves of
size n of epsilon then we can get the
overhead down to be order 1 and that
some of the techniques that we use are
some of the same techniques that you may
have recall that you've heard this week
already of cuckoo hashing MapReduce data
oblivious external memory some of the
things we've talked about in this
workshop already come into play in how
we do these simulations so I'm going to
talk a little bit about that as well and
then we also have some results on more
specialized computations like if you're
trying to do
finding a convex hull of some points in
the plane or you want to do all nearest
neighbor finding for some say learning
or classification algorithm that you're
doing we have data oblivious versions of
those specific algorithms as well
alright so let's talk then about this
general framework how can we get to take
any general algorithm that does you know
whatever any kind of non oblivious
computation and convert it and simulate
it in a way that hides the access
patterns one of the ingredients we use
is this so-called cuckoo hashing which
you may have been familiar with already
or you'll recall that we've talked about
already this week so let me just review
this very briefly the idea in the cuckoo
hashing framework is you have to look up
tables a T is 0 a T 1 and 2 hash
functions random hash functions and
every item is either stored in T 0 of H
0 of X or T 1 of H 1 of X and then the
standard way then you would insert
something is with this so-called so
here's a picture of that framework that
you have the table T 0 or now I'm
calling it T 1 and another table T 2 and
every element has two places it could go
either some more on the left side side
or somewhere on the right hand side so
those are the only two places it can be
so it's really easy to look up just look
up in those two places but then when you
insert then there could be some
collisions so you have to handle how you
would process the collisions and the way
you do it is like the cuckoo Bert's the
way they lay their eggs so when those
cuckoo bird lays his eggs and the nest
he kicks out the eggs that are already
in the nest and then lays his eggs and
then whoever owned the nest comes and
raises his kids not saying this is a
good way to parent but it's how the
cuckoo birds do it so when you insert
something you just put it in the spot
that you want it to go in and if there
was already an element in that cell you
evict it and send it over to the other
side and then if there was something in
that cell you evict that and send it to
the other side and you keep doing this
until either you get into an infinite
loop and then you have to like redo
everything or until you find an empty
spot and then you just stick it in and
you stop the process so this is how
cuckoo hashing works and then Michael
Minson mocker who had had to leave
unfortunately has done a lot of analysis
and sort of how these things work and
what are ways you can boost the
probability of success one of the ways
you can do that using their result is to
use whether they call a little cash a
little stash as they called it that
would store elements that would bounce
around and normally would cause an
infinite loop you say what I don't want
to redo everything I'm just going to put
you over into this little stash
cash and then you just have this added
overhead of anytime you want to do an
access you need to look in the stash as
well and that can boost the
probabilities of success to be one minus
one over N to the C so you get a big
jump in the success probability but this
still wasn't low enough failure
probability for our framework so we
actually had to use not a huge but a
bigger stash than just the constant size
so we're gonna use a stash of size log n
where n is the number of elements in the
table and we show that in this framework
the failure probability becomes
negligible in the cryptographic sense so
very very small probability of failure
but then we still have the question of
alright you want to use cuckoo tables
and these simulation results but you
have to have a way of building them and
you want to not only build them to be
efficient but they also the building
process itself needs to be data
oblivious how do you do that well that's
where we use another idea that has been
discussed this week and that's this
concept of MapReduce
so again MapReduce is this framework for
doing large computations in the cloud or
in you know in distributed computing in
general and it's as you've already heard
this week has this framework of how you
design the algorithm that you first have
a map phase where you have for every so
you hit you start with just a bunch of
key value pairs on unorganised for every
key value pair you can map it to some
sequence of others then you do a shuffle
where you bring together all the key
value pairs that have the same key sort
of a parallel hashing step is that what
they call the shuffle and then you have
this reduce where for every one of those
lists you get to process that list and
do some sort of a computation on this
and then if you want you can even
iterate and and go around and and repeat
this until your computation is done so
that's the MapReduce framework and
what we did is to design data oblivious
MapReduce algorithm that then would
build a cuckoo hash table so that's sort
of the the idea there so you want to
just basically this the idea is that you
would just simulate a whole bunch of
insertions all at once into the cuckoo
tables some fraction of them are gonna
succeed every time and then you just
keep repeating until all the the cuckoo
table is built but then okay this is
like levels of indirection now we still
need to have a data oblivious way to
simulate a MapReduce algorithm so that
was sort of one extra thing that we also
then added is how can you simulate
MapReduce algorithms in this framework
and it turns out it's not that difficult
what you do is every one of those steps
that's that's you know doing a map
that's already oblivious doing a reduced
that was oblivious these things can
happen in the internal memory of Alice
herself so it's only really the shuffle
that you have to try to figure out how
to do data obliviously and for that then
what we did is we designed a data
oblivious sorting algorithm basically a
sorting Network that would work even if
you're in this external memory framework
of you know if you had big cache lines
and you wanted to be reading big blocks
of data could you still do this
sorting very efficiently and in a way
that never reveals your access patterns
so and particularly we had a running
time if n things are being sorted and
you had blocks of size B and a memory of
size M we had this number of i/os
that can achieve that and the algorithm
is is I'm not going to go over these
details but it's basically a
generalization of the odd-even merge
sort but now using blocks instead of
just individual items to achieve that so
then the simulation then of how can we
then hide our access patterns from Bob
how do we go about doing that
is to not just have a single cuckoo
table we're actually going to have order
log n of them so sort of a whole
sequence of cuckoo tables each one is
twice the size of the one before so and
these are where you're going to store
your key value pairs of the things you
want to be looking up by their indices
initially they're all empty except for
the last one which are just all your
data that you just have sitting there
and then every time you access an item
you first look up the item where it
belongs and then or you first look in
the in the the very first level which is
just a regular cache it's like our stash
and then you look in each of the tables
but now you're gonna do a lookup using
the cuckoo functions to try to find out
where they are so that's just a random
location you're not revealing anything
to the adversary because you're always
looking using random hash functions
every time and then as soon as you find
the thing you're looking for
of course the adversary doesn't realize
you found it yet but he's just seeing
you do these random accesses to each of
these cuckoo hash tables and as soon as
you find it then you say okay I've got
it but I still need to hide my access
pattern so now I'm just gonna look for a
random thing in all the other tables so
just do random lookups after that so
again confuse the adversary and then
when we're done after you've you know
search through the log n levels then you
insert the one that you found you put it
in but you put it in at the top hash
table and then every now and then you
know at the appropriate time intervals
as these tables fill up you have this
sort of again that's cascades of tables
you then empty out a table and put it
into the next bigger one so you're
always having fresh places where you can
go and look you always have fresh
randomness to to be searching and then
this allows you to then do these
overheads with your log squared n if you
only have constant amount of local
memory or log and overhead if you have
some end of the epsilon again I'm going
over some skipping some details here but
that gives you sort of the big picture
of how this framework works so let's
talk a little bit about you know how
specialized algorithms can work so like
for convex hull you have a bunch of
points in the plane
you want to find their convex hull then
you want to now do this in this data
blue via sway you want to find the
convex hull but not reveal to the
adversary what your convex hull is the
only thing you would reveal is the fact
hey I'm finding a comics hall and that's
all he gets to learn so first you need
to sort of talk about what is you know
that the output what is the
representation that we're going to use
for how we even describe an output and
for this what we'll say is that for
every point that's in your set just
shooter array vertically up from that
point and the edge of the convex hull
that you would hit you then label that
point with that edge so if the point is
on the convex hull then he would just be
labeled with some incident edge for him
on the comic so and then somebody's on
the inside
you'd get labeled with the edge you hit
by going up and similar you can do the
same thing going down and now you've got
the a representation of the convex hull
for all your points and the way that
we're going to do this is to apply the
divide-and-conquer approach where i
didn't know how to sort things data
obliviously we've already talked about
that and now we're gonna just do a
simple divide and conquer algorithm
where you divide your data into two
halves one on the left on the right
recursively find this representation for
the convex hulls on the two sides and
then somehow merge those two solutions
and the merging of the two solutions is
in this case just finding this upper
tangent and then relabeling everybody
underneath them to then say that that's
the the edge that you would shoot if you
shoot up and there's you know admittedly
a lot of cases to consider about how to
find that opera hall but for most of
them just knowing your local information
you then can figure out and and do a
binary search for how you would go about
locating the upper Hall
the only catch with this is that doing a
binary search on some representation of
the upper Hall is itself going to reveal
where the upper tangent is so somehow
that we even have to try to hide where
is you know you're not doing this binary
search anymore you have to try
do something else so instead of trying
to do the classic binary search
algorithm anymore
we designed a date oblivious way to
search for that upper hall and instead
yeah I'm not gonna go over these details
so it's a little bit more complicated
we're gonna you know do a square root
end type of divide our binary search
not even binary anymore it's more of a
parallel search and you can just with a
constant number of probes find where you
need to where the upper hall goes and
then there's additional case analysis
involved there too I'm gonna skip all
this the result in the end then was we
were able to show that there was an
oblivious linear time method for finding
the komarin upper tangent of two
oblivious halls and then therefore you
put that into a divide and conquer
algorithm that itself is gonna be able
if he should get an order n log n so
that sort of the point is that with a
specialized algorithm for solving this
problem we were able to achieve the same
kind of running time you'd get with a
non oblivious algorithm so there's no
overhead payment involved all you're
doing is just revealing that you were
doing a convex hull algorithm so another
problem we looked at was nearest
neighbors this is a problem for example
that's used in many classification type
algorithms so you have a bunch of points
for every point you want to find what it
is his nearest neighbor in this set and
the way that we did this is is to design
data oblivious solutions for a number of
I think important steps that are used in
a lot of other algorithms one is to find
and build a compressed quadtree
representation of your data so how can
you build this data structure that's
very common and also do something called
the well separated pair decomposition
for how you would then be able to search
and and represent some set of data
so first the quadtree so the quadtree is
a is probably familiar with a simple
data structure for representing either
images or points this is the point
version of it if you have a collection
of points in some kind of a list state
small dimensional bounding box in this
case two dimensions the idea is you just
divide that space into four squares and
then keep recursing down and stewing the
splits for any of these squares that are
non-empty and thereby doing youyou get
this tree representation where the nodes
correspond to each of those splits that
you did of your data and what's what's
interesting here is that of course just
building this is going to reveal
information about your data but we were
able to find a date oblivious way to
construct it and one of the tricks that
we used is this this fact that may be
already familiar whether it's due to
that so mentioned I think it's
rediscovered many times but it's
mentioned in an ensemble spoke that if
you want to build a quadtree on data
that's from you know a computer so these
these points are represented in binary
what you can do is for all your points
take their x coordinates in their Y
coordinates and then interleave them and
then if you sort based on that ordering
then you actually get an order that is
going to visit the cells of the quadtree
in the so-called Z order representation
so you get actually a way of implicitly
representing the quadtree just from that
sorted order and then we just build the
quadtree based on that and so that's how
we build the quadtree you know again
hi-bred broad brush strokes how we do
that and then there's another construct
that's used in a lot of geometric
algorithms that process data need to
know about distances it's also it's also
related to n body simulation z'
multipole copy
Asians have very similar kind of a thing
and this is called the well separated
pair decomposition the idea is you have
a set of endpoints in some metric space
let's say Euclidean space and you would
like to decompose them into pairs of
subsets so an a1 b1 a2 b2 and so on such
that for every pair every one of these
pairs you've grouped up the the distance
between the two sets is bigger than the
size the diameter of each of those sets
on each side so in other words each of
those pairs corresponds to sort of a
well separated way of looking at your
data and it turns out you can do this in
a way that the representation is of size
and it's linear size and even though
it's representing N squared type of
relationships you nevertheless have
order in size representation and then
what's useful there is that for like n
body simulations or nearest neighbor
computations various kinds of things
typically what you can do is that since
the two sets are so far apart you can
sort of build you know one concise
representation that may be using the
center of mass or something from one set
and use that as sort of an approximation
for all the points on the other side and
how they might be influencing you and so
on so building this this thing is useful
for all nearest neighbor calculations as
well as these and body simulations and
so what we did is is to show how you
could use the quadtree
to build this and then build this this
representation in a date of livius way
so to conclude then what we've shown is
how to solve you know various geometric
and general problems in this data
Bolivia's way how you can do in fact it
turns out that you can even use these in
various kinds of simulations that
preserve privacy and more general kind
of computations and then we leave is an
open problem how you would then say try
to solve a Voronoi diagram a Dulaney
triangulation in similar kind of bounds
building this graph right
we don't know how to do that optimally
in a date of livius way and then in
terms of publications here's a set of
publications that again I've sort of not
been just talking about run result but a
whole class of results a lot of these
are with collaborators michaelm it's a
mocker who gave a talk here yesterday
and roberto thomas sia who's at brown
university thank you so we've set a
pretty high threshold admittedly for
what we consider privacy-preserving
so the only thing that we want to allow
for revealing is the size of the data
and so with that assumption that you're
only revealing the size of the data or
in these other cases the size of the
data and the name of the algorithm we're
using then they are perfectly
privacy-preserving the you're not going
to reveal any information about the data
values themselves well then there's
there's so there's the trade off so
either if it's like with the convex hull
we're matching that the the best you can
do even using a you know non oblivious
algorithm so that's matching the lower
bounds same thing with all nearest
neighbors that's matching the lower
bounds and then for the general
simulations you're paying this price you
know you're paying this price of like
this log squared overhead or log an
overhead that you're definitely off from
the optimal but that was you know this
was super general framework to do that
right yeah yeah so I was I was comparing
to the worst case because you have to
because otherwise you're revealing
information that's right
that's right
oh yeah so it's definitely extremely
related to the circuit complexity so
anything that you can do with the
circuit automatically is going to be
data oblivious well then the other way
is to use randomization so so you can
either use a circuit and that's a
deterministic so any deterministic date
oblivious algorithm is a circuit it just
is and then if you use randomization
then every time you run the algorithm
it's going to depend on the bits you use
not on the data values I mean they're
random bits you use not the data values
it's equivalent right it's exactly
equivalent cuz a date oblivious
algorithm is a circuit right yeah
all right